they're the coolest people on the earth
until you put some wolf and then it's
like you're not so lucky
like making a real zero dark thirty on
you alright so before we even dive into
this video I just want to get a few
things clear astrology is real yeah
basically what I'm gonna do today is I'm
gonna give you my true feelings about
all the astrological signs I know you
that's what you want it's my opinion on
all things I'm just gonna say start in
advance
looking at you Pisces sorry in advance
Aries Aries are leaders I feel it Aries
are very opinionated usually they feel
like their opinion is the right one
actually a lot of times it is they're
they're very that's why they're
natural-born leaders they've they're
very confident they're courageous I mean
you need that leadership on the other
hand on the flip side Aries can be a
little aggressive they can be impulsive
kind of moody you know I think because
they're leaders so if people aren't
doing it the way they like that probably
doesn't go well I know several Aries
Reba's and Aries my brother is an area's
my three-year-old son is in Aries my
stylist is in Aries my makeup artist is
an Aries and I will say that's true on
all the good and bad Taurus the best
sign obviously because that's mine you
don't shake your head at me twice the
good is that we're very loyal we're very
down to earth I feel like I'm one of
those people that kind of brings a lot
of different people together I will say
on the negative I am SuperDuper stubborn
I am a passionate person I say that's a
negative because passion can be volatile
at times like I can get super I have a
temper what see Tauruses are super
generally chill like in our when we're
working in our positive but boy you find
us working on that negative you should
just turn around from a little bit
responsible and stable not to adjectives
I love geminis I think Gemini's are so
fun because you just never know which
one you're gonna get they can kind of be
in all different kinds of circles
because they're two people in there but
I will say this man they're the coolest
people on the earth until you piss them
off and then it's like you're not so
lucky
baking a real zero dark thirty audience
which I love I'm surrounded by Gemini's
and Scorpios [ __ ] oh I definitely say
the cancers I know are persuasive
emotional tenacious suspicious and
manipulative yep nope my mom is a Leo I
know a few Leo's they're very smart
they're very intellectual cyanide feel
like a lot of the Leos I know like
especially my mom like she's a she's
like a born leader like when I watched
her like as a teacher she's a born
leader and like very creative very witty
very smart there that's a fire sign
right yeah I would say fire I feel like
a weakness of the Lea's that have been
my life as they they can second-guess
themselves their confidence even though
they shouldn't because I feel like Leo's
are very like when they're in their
positive they're like the most amazing
humans here's my thing with Virgo I have
run into virgos that I love and you know
then once I don't at all virgos are
usually very charming very charismatic
feel like they're pretty loyal I feel
like the negative of virgos we are
really critical of themselves and then
they project it on other I can be
self-critical myself because I'm a
performer I think a lot of artists can
be critical of themselves just wait till
you're older artists you won't give your
your bar will like basically disappear
Libra I don't really know any libras I
don't think the strings are cooperative
well I want to be friends with libras
okay I mean here's my thing with grudges
and I've really been like screwed over
but like don't hold on to that cuz you
know what that person doesn't care
they're not thinking about it like so
why are you thinking about it like I
don't get grudges now I will say this I
don't forget I'll forgive but I don't
forget Mama's not stupid not touching
that fire twice Scorpios are awesome my
assistant my sister my nanny like
everybody around me is a Scorpio I feel
like you don't want to piss them off
they'll come for you and they don't need
an army they're like an army all on
their own I think everything is intense
like it's whatever the emotion is with
them if they love you they love you
deeply if they're pissed off at you they
will never like you
I feel like Scorpios can't hold grudges
you let those Mossberg feel frozen back
there like with her smile like I ain't
gonna because you know what Scorpios
aren't yes people I don't know one maybe
yes person I'd actually like to find one
that's a yes person no it's like no I'm
just kidding I don't like to be
surrounded by its people but yeah that
was they are true friends they're good
Sagittarius very good men to marry
I like Sagittarius obviously I married
one they're loyal they're loyal and they
love you but they're very hard they're
perfectionists they have a very high bar
for what to expect from humans like
we're like oh we got a ranch and like
let's do this and he has already built
out the entire ranch and I'm like still
working on this one thing and I'm like
well let's slow down like he is such a
visionary
I had to rein him in sometimes because I
like it's so grand a vision and all the
scenarios I know are like that I would
say the capricoins I know I am mild
tempered I would say they're very loyal
actually very smart more of an introvert
rather than an extrovert
honestly the capricorns I know I think
the last one only applies in the
negative maybe I know like really great
capricorns working in there positive
maybe that's it
I think I only have one I think Robert
my hair guy aren't you an Aquarius yeah
he's in Aquarius yeah I do who's another
Aquarius you're an Aquarius no I knew
your birthday Van Dyne into those
Aquarius oh my gosh my yeah I have I
know people that are Aquarius way more
now that you just said that I don't
think I knew Aquarius like the dates on
that one whoops you know what because
it's not tourists it doesn't matter I
actually think that most Aquarius are
really good leaders ones I know
I'd say patient I would say they're
patient Oh take charismatic as one aloof
oh my god the universe just nailed you
what's Pisces again cuz I don't know
it's a Pisces incident while I'm not
gonna interrupt you huh okay
gentle wise I think I know many Pisces
wait that's me I'm a Taurus who doesn't
want to escape reality especially the
one we're looking him now oh okay sorry
Pisces top three Taurus Scorpio Gemini
the not-so-great ones
ergo I mean I guess like I'm not really
surrounded by many like Pisces so I'll
put them in the night I mean then maybe
I don't like them energy-wise maybe
that's why I don't know anybody's what
was the third what was what I didn't
really like do you remember oh cancer
cancer can be hard but kids I could be
cool too but I'd say if I had to pick
okay there's my bond three I think what
we've discovered here today is that I
don't know it's none about astrology I
just know the miss signs that surround
me and the ones that are you know kind
of impacting my life directly those are
the ones I kind of know a lot about
there's like a few Suns
I don't even around people with those
signs it's crazy I'm around a lot of
people think about it now you would just
gave you the definitions don't think
about people's birthdays and go that's
right she got it right
take that Neil deGrasse Tyson I don't
have to be an astrophysicist I just have
to be awesome
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going